وهنا ليس هذا هو السلاح فقط سلاح اخر
امضاء الخنادق من خرسون وبخمود الى
سوليدار الى ميكو لايف تنتشر هذه الخنادق
بالاضافه الى خنادق اخرى تم تشيدها على
طول حدود اوكرانيا مع بيلاروسيا لتشكل
جميعها خط الدفاع الاول للجنود
الاوكرانيين في مواجهه روسيا يعيش
المجندون الشتاء في الخنادق مثل جميع
الجنود منذ قرون النظم تشكل تلك المواقع
مصدات الدفاعيه مصممه للوقوف في وجه اي
هجوم كما تعطل الخنادق والتحصنات اي توغل
محتمل في تلك المنطقه لكن الارضيه الصلبه
التي يفضلها بنات هذه الخنادق قد تجعل من
السهل على العدو التقدم وقد يشكل موقعهم
احيانا هدفا سهلا ان تم استهدافه من على
القمم العاليه تستقبل
الخنادق جنود العدو مسلحين بالقنابل
اليدويه والبنادق الرشاشه ويحاولون
الاقتراب قدر المستطاع لمجرد القاء
القنابل اليدويه على الخنادق في معظم
الاحيان يموت الجنود في كتل من الطين
الملوثه على حدود هذه الخنادق
بين الحياه والموت تقف ارواح الجنود بين
الجدارين تحت الارض بين الصقيع ونيران
المدافع متسلحين بخنادقهم في المنطقه
المحرمه
الخناقه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه